the taliban have held their first news
conference since they took power in
afghanistan they put out a message
calling for women and former officials
to join their government the group's
co-founder mula abdulgani baradar has
returned to afghanistan for the first
time in nearly 20 years baradar who was
captured and arrested in pakistan was
released three years ago at the request
of the former u.s president donald trump
so that he could take part in peace
talks
but as he touched down in kandahar many
remain skeptical about the taliban's pr
push inside and outside the country
desperate people trying to flee the
country
but on the streets of afghanistan's
capital armed taliban fighters are
showing a sense of calm backed up by
their weapons
like these militants outside the afghan
interior ministry despite the guns their
message is to convince the afghan people
that there is nothing to be afraid of
we want the people to come to their
workplaces or offices there's no problem
on the part of the islamic emirate and
the people of the nation should not fear
the mujahideen of the islamic emirate of
afghanistan because the nation is from
the mujahideen and the mujahideen are
from the nation
undermining the received wisdom of the
taliban's hostility towards women this
taliban leader engaged with a female
presenter in a tv interview an
unprecedented move for the islamist
group and perhaps part of a wider move
to tap into the desire for peace and
allay the very real fears that women are
not safe
it was a line that was reiterated in a
taliban press conference later
women would be afforded all their rights
whether it is in work or other
activities because women
are a key part of society
and
we are guaranteeing all their rights
within the limits of islam
an attempt to show a moderate side
perhaps but many are skeptical of a
group which presided over brutal
punishments and severe restrictions for
women
superficially though the taliban
presence appeared to be not so
unsettling for the residents of kabul
some went about their daily tasks either
out of curiosity to see how things are
under the new taliban
or out of necessity
most of those out on the streets were
male
this woman though expressed a desire for
peace
[Music]
i want to give this message to the youth
that many young people
the other is still alive
conflict has been a part of their lives
for so long that many afghans are
desperate for peace
but extremely wary of the promises being
made by the taliban
for the latest we can speak now to
journalist franz marty he is standing by
in kabul uh france let's start with mula
abdulgani baradar tell us more about who
he is and what his return means for this
new taliban era
he was one of the the taliban founders
taliban leaders spent years in a jail in
pakistan was released
to move forward the peace process
that led to the u.s taliban agreement
and then afterwards like negotiations
between the taliban and the the
government um he's one of three deputies
of the taliban main leader responsible
for political affairs so his return
might signal that
aliban forward with like announcing
we're trying to announce like a new
government a new order in more detail
um it should be noted that the inner
workings of the taliban are obscure i
mean there are like assessments analysis
on it but at least i myself have never
met someone who can convincingly say how
the taliban exactly operate so how much
clout he has uh how much he can decide
is really like open up for speculation
um outside the taliban movement well
what about the messaging we saw from the
taliban yesterday they're saying they
have changed they won't take revenge on
enemies they will respect women's rights
within the framework of islamic law
what do people there in kabul make of
these statements
first of all it should be noted these
are not new statements that taliban have
since month if not since years like
again and again reiterated uh that they
respect women's rights that they
don't
kill people that have worked for the
government
that their arms are open
of course they remain vague and always
caveat this under islamic principle and
so on and now uh it remains to be seen
like how harsh they implement this in
areas where they have already exerted
control uh it varied how how restrictive
they were or or how much they can first
enforce certain rules and he in combo
like the reaction really or the whole
bandwidth uh some people are panicking i
think the taliban will eventually um
kill people out of revenge and they try
to flee uh by whatever means possible
other are happy that the fighting is for
now over and expressed to me um
explicitly that they're happy that the
taliban are here and that everything is
quiet and that everything seems to be
more or less under control and there is
no fighting and then you have everything
in between these extreme positions
well give us an idea for france of how
things look on the ground it is day
three under taliban rule
they're in kabul is there some type of
normalcy now setting in
today i haven't been out on the street
yet yesterday when i was it was some
type of normalcy there was less traffic
less people on the road many shops still
closed others opened and it seemed quite
normal the atmosphere was a little bit
quieter everyone seemed to will to to
kind of
not talk too much or like not say too
much because not being not sure what
happened there were some taliban
checkpoints but at least when i passed
them the taliban were just standing
there and not doing anything not
checking people um in other parts near
the airport this has apparently been
different in other parts even like main
traffic circles there was literally like
no taliban around and just like a little
bit uh civilian traffic uh so so that
there there has been like little of
exerting physical control except that
taliban can be seen in certain parts of
the of the street um this might this
will probably change uh once a taliban
um like have a stronger grip on things
and france last question we're focusing
very much on kabul but can you tell us
how things are in the rest of the
country
i have today in the morning called
several people in several cities uh the
the general
assessment is uh generally people told
me everything is quiet a little bit what
i said here the situation in kabul that
taliban are on the street but they ain't
they don't interact much with civilians
they don't harass them um there have
been like a few reports to the country
they are often hard to verify but all in
all it seems to be also in provincial
capitals rather calm that said radio
journalists from kunar told me yesterday
that
the taliban came to a station and they
requested or demanded that there will be
no music played
so this shows that the taliban might
soon begin
to to again implement harsher
restrictions
if they haven't already done so
journalist franz mardi speaking to us
from couple thank you very much for that
update
well a german flight carrying evacuees
from afghanistan has landed in frankfurt
it's one of three special flights
carrying people to germany as many
countries rush to evacuate their
citizens and staff from kabul the
government in berlin has been criticized
for the slow pace of its evacuation
campaign but the foreign ministry says
it is stepping up efforts to get more
people out of afghanistan
a plane full of people escaping taliban
rule
images shared by the german military of
its third rescue flight out of kabul
by contrast the first three german
planes that flew to afghanistan only
brought a few people out
one flight left kabul on monday night
with only seven passengers on board
the security situation meant more could
not be taken germany's strategy is to
use the airport in tashkent the capital
of neighboring uzbekistan as a base for
evacuations they will then be flown on
civilian airliners back to germany
the first transport plane landed in
tashkent on tuesday bringing around 125
german embassy and support staff but
also citizens of other nations
the german government says the operation
will assist anyone who can make it to
kabul airport
but there is fierce criticism of its
handling of afghans who work for the
german army
this german officer runs an organization
that sets up safe houses for local
support staff in kabul
he says that official rescue efforts are
too little too late
we stopped running safe houses for local
people and we told them to leave them
now that they've become death traps
the taliban are going door to door
looking for local forces
and all i hear the constant lies and
have truths to cover up what happened
those of us who worked with local
afghans have no understanding for this i
listen to the cries for help 400 to 500
of them every day and it leaves its mark
on us
thousands demonstrated in berlin and
other cities to demand an unbureaucratic
evacuation process and a welcome for
people who want to come to germany
they too are angry that the german
government had not prepared better for
the return of the taliban
for those who want to leave afghanistan
help is on its way
what is not clear is how many of them
will be able to go
for women and girls in afghanistan the
return of the taliban has meant fear and
uncertainty
since the extremists were ousted two
decades ago women have taken on a more
prominent role in society in politics
women were guaranteed more than a
quarter of parliamentary seats several
have held ministerial positions like
surya dalil here who was served as
minister of public health and was later
named afghanistan's permanent
representative to the u.n
in the security forces as well women
made an impact by joining the police and
the army some of them rose through the
ranks like brigadier general kaltul
muhammad zai who we see here now the
percentage of girls and women receiving
an education also increased
significantly the taliban had long
prohibited schooling for girls past the
age of 10.
now around a fifth of all university
students are women
under the taliban regime access to basic
health care was also often restricted
for women a lot changed over the past 20
years and now many fear afghanistan's
women might be once again stripped of
their hard-earned rights
now for more on this we have with us
here in our studio our reporter abrigat
ashoka she has spent many years
reporting in afghanistan covering
women's rights and issues and she's here
to talk a little bit more about this
topic with us regita thanks for joining
us it does seem like the taliban is
trying to portray this image of a
changed face that they will provide more
rights to women and girls and respect
their role in society within the
framework of islamic law
what do you think women will be able to
expect now
i think to be honest nobody nobody can
tell right now
we sense a huge
insecurity um by by the female a lot uh
went into hiding
um they are scared because often the
taliban have said one thing and done the
opposite
so the question is like women rights
under sharia law what does that really
mean which which
rights do they do they address like is
it educational rights is it rights for
representation political rights so
all the all the women we spoke to they
don't know if they can go to university
further they don't know if women are
like
allowed to work anymore and in this
insecurity
car wool is changing already
it's small changes but over the last two
days we have seen much less um
women on the streets female presenters
in television have been replaced by
their my colleagues and
and this is just a small thing but a big
sign the price for workers has doubled
on the market in uh in kabul over the
last two days you mentioned universities
there are many girls in afghanistan who
have not yet finished their education do
they have to fear for their future
i mean they definitely fear for their
future now and we saw this in other
provinces like herat when a taliban took
control there
and
girls or young students weren't female
students weren't allowed anymore on
campus so many teachers and also
students
like fear that they won't be able to
finish their education
maybe not now but um once the
international community doesn't look
anymore so closely they really fear that
something uh the the rights their rights
to study or to have education will be
diminished and this would be a huge
setback because over the last um
years we have seen a new generation of
of females who were self-confident um
starting business uh well educated and
they did a huge contribution to society
and they were also role models to those
who are in universities now and really
want to finish the education well we've
seen germany now saying that it's
suspending its development operations
right now because of the situation on
the ground won't that just leave women
and girls even more vulnerable going
forward
yes absolutely women girls but also the
poor because um more uh just close to a
half
of the population is living under the
national um poverty line and a lot of
international aid has gone into food aid
but yes also in in in women's projects
um like empowerment like small loan
programs like
um
i don't know training for judges
on women rights so i i could go on for
for years and definitely if you cut back
the um the funding for these sort of
projects it will have
a huge impact on on the women's world
especially in the rural areas and that's
why a lot of organizations have pledged
to the international community and to
germany to not stop uh the funding um to
just i mean because you have to doubt
that it has an effect on the taliban but
it will definitely have an effect on on
girls and women and because you have a
lot of contacts on the ground in
afghanistan what are they telling you
right now
i mean this everybody has this sense of
insecurity and and in the the first day
after after the taliban took over there
was sheer panic and the people were
really
they they felt left alone and and i got
a lot of messages now the situation is
calming down a little bit people
have gone as i said into hiding and the
problem is that even in kabul they they
can trust the rules because they they
told me that in each quarter or part of
kabul um other regional commanders of
the taliban have their own rules so huge
insecurity and
some told me if they can leave they will
do immediately dw's forget to shulker
with us thank you so much for sharing
your reporting